i was talking this morning about the
video specifically uptown girl i think
this is the greatest
[ __ ] moment when you step out of that
car at a minute 41
in which i know howard at a minute 41
you step out you're in the hat
your legs they they focus on your legs
and your feet yeah and you're dancing
around
you still know the dance moves don't you
the reason this is so great first of all
knowing billy joel
the fact that did you get him to dance
in that you know i didn't um
it uh it was actually his friend uh
john small who directed it
who directed all his videos at the time
and john
just had this idea and really you know
just listened to the song and came up
with this thing
and the funny thing was was there a lot
of rehearsal because it does seem like
you guys did choreography
and you want to hear something it was
the hottest
night of the summer we're down downtown
across the street from the old cbgb's
right
right there was that little gas station
there it was so
hot that every step the heels of my
shoes
would sink into the tarmac of the
because the the asphalt starts to melt a
little bit melted
and every kick like my shoe would go up
you know
and just be like stuck down there
how long does it take to shoot something
like that we were there all night
we started late it was so much fun was
it was it so much fun was it highly
discussed between you and billy because
you're married and you say
should we go no as a matter of fact it
happened
very spontaneously the whole thing was
put together very quickly
right and uh and they were talking about
it and and
uh they said and of course we're going
to need an uptown girl and and billy
said you know well
what's wrong with my wife christy do you
want to do it and i said sure
yeah and uh and so you know like a
couple
days later there we were doing it right
uh of course i got in trouble
with screen actors guild because i
because i didn't know that i had to like
get paid for it
right it's your husband right well we
weren't married at the time
see you know um so rules were broken
because you didn't even have time to
discuss it with your management
it's okay it's my husband my boyfriend
we amended it it would have to
be union is that the greatest
aphrodisiac here's your boyfriend
he's written a song uptown girl you
assumed it was about you right
billy claims it's about l mcpherson do
you what do you buy into on that
actually um i think he came on your show
yes and said no it wasn't about elle
yeah
it was about me but but he was
he was dating l for you know a few
minutes before
like it's a legendary story yeah we we
all met at the same time
where were you you were on vacation we
were in saint bart
i was working i wasn't on vacation i was
down there with a magazine
mcpherson elle was down there she was
brand new to the business she was down
there with a different magazine
and whitney houston was down there and
whitney houston was undiscovered and
just the cutest little girl at the time
right do you when that happens the three
of you are in the same area together
i was in gustavia the main main village
having dinner
with my hairdresser friend maury hobson
right
and all of a sudden somebody comes
running and goes billy joel's at the bar
at the plm and um and hops is like like
he stands up right away and goes oh come
on let's go let's go
of course and i said who's billy joel oh
is that true
i was living in paris for four years so
i had no idea
when i found out that he was the guy
from my favorite french radio show that
wrote
[Laughter]
so i had no idea and one night that you
know he started playing that i was like
wait a minute you so he's listening to
the same radio show in paris as me and
he goes
no actually i wrote that you thought it
was the thing
so so he probably dug that you didn't
know who he was right because you know
guys are always on guard
well i kind of didn't i didn't say that
you know i was
had more manners than that but i just
said to him because
i had no idea if he was like from the
south and his name was like
billy joel something yeah billy joel
mcallister yeah
so i just said you know you look like a
joe to me and i called him joe forever i
never called him anything but joe
were you thinking hmm boyfriend material
here oh no no he was
burnt as he was a red as a lobster he
was shiny he was like
in like a hawaiian tourist shirt but
when billy starts playing let's face it
yeah well you know what i barely let him
play because he sat down at the piano to
like do his
he told me later he said i was shooting
my best billy joel album covers your way
you know right and and i wasn't paying
any attention and he's trying to show
you his superpowers yeah and he sits
down to play the piano and i
scooch over on the bench and start
singing
he could barely get a song in edgewise
finally he starts to sing yeah and then
and at that point
l appears and she was sort of like
slinking over yes linking on around on
the
you weren't coming on heavily she was
coming on and she's
got the body that doesn't need much all
she has to do is
lean against something and she looks
incredible right and as she's like
looking all
sexy and hot and incredible um and
billy's finally got the mic from me
right right he starts into one of his
songs and all of a sudden there's
whitney
um i've got a song yeah i'd like to sing
and and he's like go away kid yeah yeah
you can't sing and she's like come on
just play a little respect
and uh and so he's like all right here
we go and then all of a sudden she's
like
he should have signed her right then and
there oh my gosh she blew everybody over
so let me understand something is it the
three of you plus billy or is there like
a whole crowd for me because billy
joel's playing
well we were up up close and center of
course
yeah you're used to that yeah and then
there were you know people starting to
collect right now because there were
there was only the plm at that point so
the rumor was that billy wrote uptown
girl for elle when he was seeing her
but we today choose to believe
that that means if that's true why
wasn't she in the video yeah
good point